I just couldn't cope with life anymore
um my instinct was I this has to stop
they were feelings that led Susie Hayes
to make three suicide attempts but two
years on she can cope with life again
helped by a crisis center called safe
space run by the mental health charity
mind it was literally what the name says
it was a safe space so much better than
going to a e
um so much Karma and there would always
be something to do if I if I needed to
just sit there and chill now a joint
pilot scheme is being run by West London
NHS trust and mind to divert those in
crisis away from overwhelmed emergency
departments towards three local centers
there are some people who present in a
crisis with a very real imminent risk of
them hurting themselves or even killing
themselves
but Mental Health Services aren't the
right thing for them because it's not
necessarily part of an illness and
there's a risk of over-medicalizing
their needs and therefore not meeting
their needs but
their distress is very real and
immediate and they need immediate help
and what this safe space does is that it
provides a whole new option to meet
those people's needs and the demand for
help is disturbingly high safe space has
helped 700 people in just over a year
new figures reveal there were
5583 suicides in England and Wales last
year around three quarters of those who
died were male but there's a worrying
increase in suicide among young women up
57 since records began in the 80s that's
obviously the cost of living crisis if
you're starting a new job or you're
going to University you've got a new
friendship group I think it's there's a
lot going on in the world at the moment
it's really it's difficult for everybody
but I think um yeah we've definitely
seen kind of a rising in young women as
well and suicide thoughts now Susie
volunteers for the charity running an
art Workshop as well as donating some of
the money she makes from selling her own
work to mind she knows firsthand how
crucial its support can be when it all
gets too much
Emma birchley Sky News West London
and if you need supports with any of the
issues raising that report so you can
contact the Samaritans the helpline is
one one six one two three that's one one
six one two three or email Joe at
samaritans.org